Who are you not who you think i am
i'm going back to the very beginning of the mcu
we have a keystone event and that event is tony
stark becoming iron man he's forced to build these
weapons for an organization and that organization
was the ten rings and there was this wonderful
character we really wanted to do something with
someday and that was shang chi when they announced
this the movie i was really really excited
kind of tongue-in-cheek i ended up tweeting marvel
hey are we gonna talk or what
so i'm very glad i did that
he's so intense as this character shang chi was
made for simu and i could feel his passion for it
the back story of sean is really unique and
that he discovered that his father was this
evil overlord the brains gave our family power
he's brought back into his father's world and has
to deal with coming face to face with him again
and this is a much meaner and more hearted father
and then crazy stuff happens after that
it's time for you to take your place
by my side that's not gonna happen
my heart was definitely in this
project it feels in line with
everything i believe in it is a crazy
wild giant ride that we're gonna go on
Welcome back everyone this is my new shang
chi trailer video and easter eggs marvel just
released even more new footage and kevin feige
just kind of blowing up everything you knew
about iron man's origin in the mcu so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's a
whole bunch of marvel what if episodes starting in
a couple weeks i'll be doing videos for all
those episodes very different spin on iron
man's origin we're going to see during that
series just because it's playing on this big
trope of the multiverse and what happened
at the end of the loki's series with kang
loki and sylvie thank you very much sylvie but
the big thing here is just kevin feige talking
about the connection between iron man tony stark
the mandarin the ten rings organization and the
truth behind his origin in the mcu so some of you
may have actually been thinking about this since
way back a couple years ago when they released the
iron man 3 one shot all hail the king and revealed
that there was a real 10 rings organization
led by the real version of the mcu mandarin
kind of making you rethink the events of
the first iron man movie just a little bit
but if it wasn't clear what kevin feige
is confirming here is that when raza the
character from iron man 1 ordered the hit on
tony stark's military convoy to steal his new
stark tech weapons it was on the orders of
the real mandarin shang chi's father wen wu
it was implied that he was working with obadiah's
stain they're basically saying that obadiah stain
was working with the real mandarin in raza was
just the intermediary for that relationship
and according to what he says even as far back
as them making that first iron man movie more
than 10 years ago now they were trying to find a
way to do shang chi's character but at the time
it sounds like they hadn't quite figured that out
they hadn't decided to just make him the mandarin
son and do the mandarin that way here's a deep cut
too if you've been following all the marvel movies
since their original comic-con when they were
hyping it up back in i think it was 2006 there was
a special mcu panel that kevin feige did where he
was hyping up the fact that they were going to be
making their own movies they were going to do an
iron man movie they were doing an incredible hulk
movie and i think way back at that comic-con panel
they may have even implied during the q a session
that they were planning on building up to the
first avengers movie characters i name that we
that we work are working on currently and you
put them all together there's no coincidence
that that may someday equal the avengers i think
uh i don't think they officially announced that
marvel phase one avengers movie plan until after
the first few movies had actually been released
but in the early days of the mcu when they were
doing these very early first comic-con panels
kevin feige was much more open to hyping up their
future plans than he is now like you talk to him
now and he tries to give nothing away but if you
watch his early interviews for some of those early
marvel phase one movies he's like oh yeah you we
are building up to something really big and it was
all him hyping up the avengers movie but you may
remember kevin feige talking about how during that
first comic con panel if you had been there in the
crowd you would have heard him say that they were
going to use the mandarin is the main villain of
that first iron man movie now this was a couple
years before they'd actually made the movie before
anything ever came out and famously they pivoted
hard on that by the time they actually started
making it and they made obadiah stain the main
villain and change some of the 10 rings plot
making them feel more like a terrorist cell
entitled a little bit more to the whole bush
administration war in iraq war in afghanistan feel
that made it feel a little bit more timely when it
was released because it was right at the tail end
of all that so just based on his comments in this
new video kevin feige is basically saying that
their original idea for that first iron man movie
was that the real mandarin of the mcu would have
originally been responsible for creating iron man
for setting in motion the sequence of events that
would lead to tony stark becoming iron man which
makes sense i mean he's one of the biggest classic
iron man comic book villains if you remember the
michael keaton batman movies the tim burton batman
movies it's a very joker batman origin situation
they even called that out during that first
michael keaton batman movie it's an old trope of
superhero comics where the main villain winds up
inadvertently creating his own worst enemy in
the hero and now weigh down the sacred timeline
of the mcu many years later thank you very much
loki sylvia and kang they're just using the shang
chi movie to clarify retroactively that yes it was
the real mandarin behind all this the whole time
kevin feige and marvel do this all the time with
the newer marvel movies using newer movies like
avengers end game to re-contextualize old movies
and make them seem even better in retrospect when
you rewatch them like all the dark world scenes
from the time travel heist in avengers end game
they make the thor the dark world movie seem
even better when you go back and re-watch it now
now i'd argue that the first iron man movie
is still one of the best marvel movies of
all time so far but after the shang chi movie
now you'll be able to go back and re-watch that
and some of the events around his origin will have
new meaning this is also the way marvel connects
the future really weird really different movies
and characters to the older movies and characters
everything that came before tom holland's
spider-man is another really good example
of that in the mcu he was around for all the big
marvel phase one stuff the infinity saga of movies
and he'll be here for all the new marvel phase
four phase five x-men fantastic four stuff as
well so he's a bridge between the past present
and the future the mcu in shang chi is just
another way of showing how important iron man is
to the foundation of the mcu and how everything is
connected how tony stark might be dead in this
reality in present day but he's still very much
connected to all the new stuff i also just did
a video about the connection between kang and
iron man and the mcu because kang is like the
next big thanos level threat in marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5. inside kang's study where he keeps
his most prized possessions if you look around
he actually keeps one of iron man's helmets in
the line of sight of his desk near the entryway
notice how there are no other avengers props
anywhere in here it's just iron man he's the
only character that he seems like he's fixated
on i'll add a link for that video at the end
of this and down in the description because the
connections between kang and iron man characters
go a little bit deeper than that there's a reason
kang is so fixated on iron man particularly
but there'll be a lot more iron man easter
eggs and callbacks like that during the
shang chi movie so i'll point those out when the
movie gets released later this year there's also
a bunch of new footage that you see during this
trailer too you see footage of him training with
michelle yeoh's character before what seems like
the big final battle of the movie when you see
his father the mandarin come back with his army
to attack these monks in this village there are
more new scenes from the fight that they worked
into this you can see behind the smaller temple
where they're fighting here is the lake separating
that special door that all these monks in michelle
yeoh's character seem like they're protecting she
said that she is the protector of an ancient city
during the movie so that's why a lot of people are
like maybe she's the great protector dragon maybe
she turns into a dragon during the movie there was
some leaked footage that got out i can't put it in
this trailer here but it's just actual footage
of the great protector dragon during the movie
you see the mandarin looking out at the lake and
you see the dragon come bursting out of it there's
also some separate footage that shows michelle
yeoh's character standing in a lineup with shang
chi his sister katie the other monk characters
having their big gunslinger standoff moment with
the mandarins army when they first show up before
the battle actually starts the whole thing with
them teasing what might be behind this door this
ancient city that they're keep referring to in the
comics it was really just the mcluhan spaceship
that was trapped inside this mountain where it
had crashed thousands and thousands of years ago
they were an ancient race of space dragon so it
was just advanced hypertext so it'd be like them
protecting a version of odin's treasure vault but
i'm assuming because they've already changed so
much about the backstory of the 10 rings of power
themselves in the mcu whatever's behind this door
is also going to be a little bit different too
there's also more new footage of the big battle
here where you see a bunch of tiny dragons
carrying one of the mandarin's men into the sky
and start ripping him apart still not totally
hundred percent on whether or not this is going to
be the mcu version of the mcluhan's there's also
more footage of the mandarin flashbacks you can
see him using the power of the 10 rings to shield
himself which is actually new we've only seen him
in the other trailers using them for attack powers
i think the whole idea with the 10 rings of power
in the mcu is that they're going to evolve their
power the same way they evolved thor's powers
like you see him in the first thor movie he uses
mjolnir for basic attacks flying around lightning
attacks by the time they get to thor ragnarok they
completely recontextualize how his powers work
you find out he's way more powerful than you
thought just because he never fully understood how
his powers worked then by avengers infinity war
he gets the boss level upgrade and stormbreaker
and becomes the most powerful version of himself
so don't be surprised if something similar happens
with shang chi's arc during the marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5 movies many years down the road
after a couple sequel movies in his franchise
we'll see if they try to pull a joke like they did
during thor ragnarok with his hammer like what are
you shang chi the god of rings it also sounds like
by the end of this movie he will also become the
new protector of this ancient city so i'm curious
now to see what's actually inside what they're
calling this ancient city and if it's going to
be used as part of the overall plot of marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5 the same way they did with
wakanda during the black panther movie a lot of
you've also asked if they're going to introduce
a new version of iron fist during these new shang
chi movies it's totally possible that feels like
it would be the place to introduce a new version
of iron fist if you're going to introduce them
in the mcu but everybody post all your theories
in the comments below what do you think is behind
this giant secret door what'll happen is there's
a whole bunch of stuff coming up next week the
suicide squad movies coming out so i'll be doing
some easter egg videos for that the marvel what
if episodes are also starting in a couple weeks so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those everyone click here
to learn about the spider-man version of doctor
strange in that new marvel what if trailer and
click here for my new loki video about how iron
man is connected to kang the conqueror in the mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!